un individuo ha perdido la capacidad
para activar células y tener una
respuesta inmune humor al inciso a
propone una consecuencia directa de la
pérdida de la actividad de células ve en
la respuesta inmune u moral del
individuo a la exposición inicial a un
mató gen o bacteriano entonces sólo como
un recordatorio de lo que son las
células ve y lo que es la respuesta
inmune u moral la respuesta inmune u
moral es aquella que implica anticuerpos
y las células vez son las que van a
reconocer un antígeno algo que el cuerpo
no quiere que esté dentro de él y en
respuesta a esos antígenos se va a
multiplicar va a diferenciarse en
células plasmáticas que producen
anticuerpos que esencialmente son estas
macromoléculas que etiquetan a los
antígenos para que puedan ser limpiados
después y luego se pueden diferenciar en
células ve de memoria para que la
próxima vez cuando ese mismo antígeno
vuelva a aparecer se pueda tener una
respuesta más rápida
así que el inciso a propone una
consecuencia directa de la pérdida de la
actividad de células ve en la respuesta
inmune u moral del individuo a la
exposición inicial a un patógeno
bacteriano pues no habrá una respuesta o
moral así que podríamos decir que no se
van
a producir
anticuerpos
por lo que
no habrá
respuesta
inmune tumoral
a la exposición
inicial
por lo que no se va a etiquetar a esos
antígenos para que luego puedan ser
limpiados por otras células del sistema
inmune nada de eso va a suceder inciso b
propone una consecuencia directa de la
pérdida de actividad de células ve en la
velocidad de la respuesta inmune u moral
del individuo a una segunda exposición
al patógeno bacteriano
no hay
células ve
de memoria
y no hay
anticuerpos
para
la segunda
exposición
al patógeno
por lo que
no hay
respuesta un moral
y la respuesta inmune
en general
será más lenta
el objetivo de las células y los
anticuerpos es que la segunda vez que
aparece el patógeno puede ser etiquetado
muy rápidamente es reconocido muy
rápidamente y entonces el sistema inmune
puede responder pero ahora eso no va a
suceder en la segunda exposición ese
reconocimiento rápido del antígeno por
lo que no va a tener la respuesta u
moral y se podría decir que la respuesta
inmune en general será más lenta y menos
efectiva
muy bien vamos a pensar en el inciso se
describe una característica de la
respuesta inmune del individuo al
patógeno bacteriano que no se ve
afectada por la pérdida de células vez
las células actúan en la respuesta
inmune u moral en la que se etiqueta las
cosas con anticuerpos y se tiene a las
células ver de memoria para que la
próxima vez que aparezca el patógeno se
tenga una respuesta más rápida pero no
es el único componente de nuestro
sistema inmune nuestro sistema inmune
tiene muchas facetas todavía va a tener
la respuesta inmune celular
todavía
va a tener la respuesta
inmune
celular
y esto implica cosas como los fagocitos
que van a engullir a los patógenos
también están las células de
y que puedan reconocer el antígeno y de
manera similar tratar de destruirlo por
lo que aún tiene la respuesta inmune
mediada por células también tienen cosas
como la piel cosas que bloquean la
entrada de los patógenos al cuerpo eso
es considerado parte del sistema
inmunológico todavía tiene
la protección
de la piel
y podrías escribir esto con más detalle
incluso si está perdiendo la función de
sus células vez éstas siguen siendo
defensas que el cuerpo tiene que tienen
como fin evitar que los patógenos entren
en el caso de la piel e incluso una vez
que los patógenos han entrado todavía
puede reconocerlos y devorar los o
destruirlos de alguna manera